[موسيقى]
الريح التي تهب بشده وترتفع الى عنان
السماء مثل العمود تسمى عند اهل اللغه
العربيه بل اعصار والعامه يسمونه بالعاصوف
والاعصار عند اهل الارصاد هي منطقه ضغط
منخفضه تجلب الرياح الى مركزها والاعصار
يمر بمراحل عده قبل تشكله يبدا منخفض جوي
بين قوسين سحب فاذا زادت حركته تحول الى
عاصفه مداريه لسرعه دورانه ولانه يتشكل في
المناطق المداريه وهي المناطق الواقعه بين
مدار السرطان الى مدار الجدي فاذا زادت
حركه دورانه عمي 118 كيلو متر بس ساعه
تحول الى اعصار يا رب سلط على الاحزان
عاصفه من المسرات لا تبقي ولا تذروا وابعث
الينا من التفريج مكرمه وامن على من غزاه
الهم
والكدر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والاعاصير خمس درجات تصنف على حسب سرعه
دورانيه حول المركز بالكيلومتر بساعه
الدرجه الاولى سرعته من 119 الى 153 وهو
ضعيف الدرجه الثانيه من 154 الى 177 وهو
متوسط الدرجه الثالثه سرعته من 178 الى
208 وهو قوي الدرجه الرابعه من 209 الى
251 وهو قوي جدا فاذا زادت سرعه دورانه عن
225 كيلو متر بساعه فهذه هي الدرجه
الخامسه وهي المدمره فالاعصار رياح عاتيه
مصحوبه بامطار غزيره واما عاد فاهلكوا
بريح صارت عاتيه
[موسيقى]